[Musica]
ciao a tutti
come avete avuto modo di sentire io sono
un musicista
e sia per me che per tutti i musicisti
esiste un grande sottosopra
ovvero quello del suono
il suo esatto contrario di silenzio è
per noi musicisti in realtà ci lancia
assume un valore importanti ma
soprattutto quando ci accingiamo a
diventare degli interpreti
professionisti
mi spiego meglio
ci troviamo di fronte a fare delle
scelte che tipo di scelte per esempio
quanto veloce quanto lento suonare
ovvero che spazio di silenzio lasciare
tra una nota e l'altra
oppure ancora quanto forte
quanto piano suonare
ovvero quanto vicino o quanto lontano
trovarti dalla soglia il silenzio
ma cos'è questo silenzio che tra l'altro
mi appartiene ma su queste ci arriveremo
dopo
bene a parlarcene una chiave nuova fu
john cage un compositore degli anni 50
che recandosi presso una camera anecoica
all università di harvard anecoica per
l'esattezza significa senza ego
massimo abbattimento delle riflessioni
del suono nessuna rifrazione sonora il
silenzio più totale lui android entro
questa camera
in realtà sentire distintamente due
suoni uno grave è un acuto allora che
sull tecnico accanto a lui ma com'è
possibile che io senta due suoni se ciò
il silenzio più totale e il tecnico
senza dubbi e risposte e ben il suono
grave in realtà proviene dal tuo sistema
cerebrale mentre quell'acuto dal sistema
circolatorio
quindi è scientificamente provato che si
lancio per numeri non esiste
allora lì che ebbe un'idea drastica
rivoluzionaria fantastica strappa la
terra dei canoni ha deciso di comporre
un brano senza scrivere un brano di puro
silenzio lo chiama 433 che sarebbero 273
secondi e richiamano ai famosi meno
273,15 gradi che rappresentano lo zero
assoluto una temperatura mai raggiunta
in questo caso stiamo parlando di si
lancia assoluto che poi è relativo poi
vi chiederete ma perchè vi sto parlando
di 4 33 beh
questo brano ci presenta due sottosopra
il primo è che sembra un brano di facile
esecuzione
che ci vuoi raccontare
273 secondi a 60 battiti al minuto senza
metronomo e senza cronometro
beh non è che sia così tanto facile
quindi un brano che sembra facile in
realtà è molto difficile da eseguire
l'altro sottosopra di un riscontro
spesso ai miei concerti per me è
bellissimo suonare per la gente
in quel momento mi sento ora mi sento un
protagonista
il pubblico gode di quello che è
protagonista fa spero
bene adesso provate a immaginare un
orchestra o un solista che salgono sul
palco il direttore dall'attacco di 433
sé tutti i musicisti restano immobili
non producono nessun suono
beh allora ci si trovano a sistema le
cose di straordinario perché si è tutti
concentrati sul silenzio che viene
disturbato dai rumori
inevitabili come improvvisi colpi di
tosse quindi se ci pensate che il gip
con 433 livella sullo stesso piano
performer pubblico entrambi fanno parte
della scena entrambi sono
protagonisti a me piace pensare
che questa unione che l'abbia fatta quel
silenzio si parta il silenzio
ha unito e unisce a tutt'oggi ma a voi
il silenzio e il mio sottosopra
io sono sordo
se io tolgo
l'impianto cocleare la protesi acustica
non sento nulla mi trova esattamente un
ottimo colori ma tu
nella camera
anecoica
accanto john cage
tra l'altro calcio dei casi questo
impianto ero messo qui a padova è noto
chirurgo che me l'hanno già andato e qui
tra di voi
il professore alessandro martini che
ringrazio e saluto calorosamente
bene
c'è una corsa mia nonna quando avevo 8
anni
perché stavo troppo vicino alla tv
allora chiesi a mia mamma di fare un
esame e lì la diagnosi fu chiara
ipoacusia neurosensoriale
bilaterale grave da quel momento
iniziò un percorso costellato di molti
sopra e tanti sopra sotto
fatto di momenti di grandi difficoltà ma
anche di enormi soddisfazioni
per esempio quando ero piccolo io avevo
paura a relazionarmi con la gente
mi sentivo addirittura inferiore
insicuro perché avevo paura che questa
sordità un giorno sarebbe stato un
problema anche la causa di esclusione
dalla vita sociale
bene oggi posso dire che ha tutta questa
paura io ho risposto col suo esatto
inverso il suo sottosopra il coraggio il
coraggio di trovare qualcosa che potesse
avvicinare queste persone di trovare
qualcosa che potesse farmi sentire
apprezzato per ciò che aereo perso che
sono il mio talento la musica quindi la
musica siete la mia salvezza
un'opportunità di sentirmi parte del
mondo
un'opportunità anche riservare
non c'è stemmi sincero da parte dei miei
genitori e la mia famiglia e gli
insegnanti i miei amici musicisti e poi
meraviglioso pubblico
la mia vita mi ha posto anche un grande
sottosopra davanti
un altro
risiede nella risposta a una domanda che
spesso mi impongono davide ma tu come
fai a suonare senza sentire meglio il
rispondo che in realtà i suoni ho
imparato a
immaginarli li sento attraverso le dita
con l'orecchio della mente
livello assumono forme si muovono
nell'aria ma concretamente cosa
significa immaginare i suoli
cosa significa sentire quell'orecchio
della mente bene immaginate una scala
che sale verso l'alto è che a un certo
punto sale così in alto che va oltre le
nuvole e che quindi voi non riuscireste
più a vederla
però se ci pensate se conoscete la sua
direzione è la pendenza io sono sicuro
che ognuno di voi potrebbe immaginarne
la sua evoluzione al di là delle nuvole
al di là della vista e in musica
funzionano allo stesso modo i suoni
musicali sono come quei gradini della
scala che sale verso l'alto ed io l'ho
dato che vedo i gradini più bassi
riesco a immaginare i gradini più alti
[Musica]
per farvi un esempio pratico
quando mi trovo di fronte allo studio di
un brano in questo caso il sesto studio
di philip glass
presenta un passaggio nel registra punto
che io non posso sentire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora lo studio dapprima nel registro
che possa sentire
[Musica]
attraverso quel processo poi di logica
della scala che sale verso l'alto queste
ore a immaginare risultato nel registro
dei suoni acuti
beh a questo punto
[Musica]
bene
questo percorso è anche regalato
un grande consiglio da dare a tutti voi
se credete in qualcosa è la volete
veramente
c'è qualcuno che è
volo impedisce non crede in voi se siete
resilienti
perseverate siete i primi voi stessi a
crederci fino in fondo
non esistono limiti per ribaltare la
situazione
sottosopra e raggiungere questi
traguardi
io per esempio
nel mio silenzio
ho trovato una ragione di vita nel suo
sottosopra il suono grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]